this is Stefan mostly talking about the
weather so a very very English topic
thank you very much
excuse at the beginning because it's a
very big topic there's a lot to talk and
I'm just skipping over I hope I have
provided a lot of links in the
presentation which you can later use if
you want to go a bit more deeper in any
topic I have also a colleague to be with
me today if you later want to have some
question or discuss with us anything we
are here to stay shortly after the
meeting to discuss something so let's
get started quickly about May I'm the
head of the developing section at ECMWF
which I will explain in a second I call
myself veteran a sufferer developed
because I'm quite long in the business
it done graphics when SGI was still
doing graphics and now getting more mode
to use to open source environmental
things but as you can see from my name's
i'm not very creative when it comes to
if you come up with my name so they get
up in twitter more importantly we're a
development section of over 20
developers now ECMWF c++ spice and a lot
web development databases of course
storing data there's a lot of
developments going on for us is a lot
about software packages we provide not
just for ourselves but for the community
around the world the methodological
community so it's a it's a very big job
for us to do their stuff in a lot of
different formats and the time
criticality of weather is very important
so that's a big driver for our
developments but I mentioned ECMWF what
is it ECMWF stands for European Centre
for medium-range weather forecasts very
short brief name we are an
intergovernmental organization so even
sort of Europe in the name we like the
European Space Agency we are integral
material so we're not part of the
European Union we do a lot of work with
the European Union as you will see from
my presentation but we're not actually
part of it so we're not directly
affected at the moment by things going
on that's right indirectly affair but we
have 22 Member States about Europe 12
cooperative States and if you look at
the map you realize there are some
countries which are member states which
are not in the European Union so we're a
bit wider than that
we are mainly located headquarter wise
in Redding UK we're starting since
December months ago we started building
a new data center in Bologna Italy that
is where in future our supercomputer
will go but the headquarter will stay in
Redding west of London here we are now
roughly 350 staff located all in reading
at the moment so what we do is mainly is
a 24/7 operational aspect of weather
forecasting and that means delivering
the forecast time critically to all our
users customers which are mostly initial
weather services but also were the
business agencies businesses this means
in practice terabytes of data being
delivered very quickly within minutes
around the world we operating to do that
HPC a supercomputer center with two
supercomputers which as I mentioned we
will move to Bologna in 2020 and we're
also operating the biggest archive for
not a metrological data with 250
petabytes pretty similar worth so you
might guess now what we're doing from
the name Europe I explained weather
forecast but you might wonder what is
medium range the medium range many
mistake for being the distance but it's
actually time and it's defined as 3 to
15 days in metrology and perhaps to
explain why we're doing it and why it's
so special for us is is you go back to
the 60s when the first idea came to
create the center is in the 60s and
beginning 70s weather forecasting
progress to do focus beyond 2 days but
if you want to do any focus beyond 3
days as you can see from the weather
system which is there on flora Florida
in within 4 days
it hits UK so if you want to do a
forecast in four days for the UK you
need you need to know what's up in the
US so to do anything you need a global
forecast and global forecasts are highly
expensive to run you need a super super
computer infrastructure it's a lot of
data involve data moving and it would be
very expensive if every weather service
would do it around the world so in the
60s the member states are shown before
came together saying let's put this
effort together because agloe
focus will be for everybody the same and
that is exactly what the center does we
provide this focus beyond three days so
if you see anywhere around the world to
focus beyond three days it's very likely
that the forecasters will have looked at
our forecast so that is something which
there are other medium range forecasts
but forecasters around the world always
take different models into account and
we are definitely one of the one they
will look at so and what does ECM that
we have provided as at Cisco as I said
operation focus I mentioned the medium
range but this medium range as I said in
the 70s we started to look three four
days now we're actually already running
monthly and seasonal forecasting and as
you can imagine when you go and these
kind of time ranges a the forecast there
will be lots of uncertainty so what we
do actually we don't run one model
we're running 52 models we run one in
high resolution one with the best
starting conditions and then 50 forecast
which in a lower resolution get slightly
tempted slightly changed a starting
condition and that will give us
statistically information about the
credibility of the forecast so if you
would run if one single forecast you
will run after lady of the week the
uncertainty of that would quite go down
but but looking at the spread of
forecast and here you can see it's
plotted on the right side the 52
different forecasts you can get
information which you then can use
statistically to analyze a certainty of
a forecast and then you have products
like on the left side which give them
the uncertainty and you can see the bars
of uncertainty over the time so in very
simple terms that is very much
simplified how our system works is you
get lots and lots of in millions tens of
millions of observations in which have
to be of course data quality needs to be
done the maps we validated all these
observations and got fed into the model
which we call the integrated forecast
system which analyzed the data does a
good starting condition for the model
and then runs the more
which has different components which I
don't go in here at the moment in this
talk but different things and then
produced a model output which we then
what we call here the product generation
is a time critical delivery to all our
users and there's also web services
because as also forecasters want to look
at past forecasts want to study a mode
in detail at the parameters of the focus
that they can do through the web
services so that's a chance and as
mentioned already we are operating very
large archive a data coming in model
output is all stored there and in the
model to do it all we run supercomputers
as I said we run two supercomputers one
research one operations and it gives us
also a fallback in case something
happened to the operation machine we can
kick off the research work and use that
machine for operations and quick word
about what comes in as I said is it's
tens of millions of observations coming
in mainly to nowadays is satellite data
there is and it might look like
satellite is now what is driving it
definitely improves the quality of the
forecast but the other observations are
very important as a reference also to
calibrate satellite so that is still
important to keep in our ended why we're
generating this plot is because we have
also a monitoring function we're giving
feedback to satellite providers to the
different agencies who collect the
weather information to say something is
possibly going wrong or the data is
biased so this means we have a lot of
statistical analysis and graphical
analysis of what we are getting in this
information to give feedback on that the
word about the model output we're
generating it's all most of the layers
of the model actually aren't Erika
harmonics representation something you
will not want to use in day-to-day work
on them we have also something called
Gaussian a grids on which model are I
worked on and these is it's very
carefully consideration when you look at
at output because if you look you might
be familiar with satellite data where
you have pixel
for which a value is for an area but if
model it's about grid points so the the
value get from the model is only valid
at this grid point if you want to have
any make any assumption or any analysis
about any point between grid points you
need to interpolate you cannot just do a
simple assumption that this point is
nearest time so that's that's very
important differences to what you would
see with satellite but very few users
work with these raw data that normally
get it already interpolated but it's
part of these product generation
software we run that we also in real
time generate it in grits how users use
it and then even then users that do
mostly two things either do the products
I show here on the on the Left where
they do take the society's 52 forecast
do statistical analysis this for example
is a map a popular forecasters it shows
anomaly anomalies so where will it be
colder than usual where will it be
hotter where will it be more wet than
usual more dry more windy so that gives
some guidance to see which in the next
two weeks possibly there will be changes
to the weather and where they then we'll
keep an eye on and then on the other
side that's see on the right side is
another important way how users look at
our data they'd settle for a location I
don't think it's reading here and then
they will have a time series of the data
of the 15 days or 10 days depending how
long the one to look at and then they
see how the parameters are looking at
will develop over time and as you can
see in the middle one quite nicely the
uncertainty over time is increasing so
that is what you expect with a further
forecast it would be weird if it would
be get but it gives weather situation
where they actually the certainty can be
better in a second week than in some
days of the first day it's kind of quick
thing about the data I mentioned already
and we're getting we're preparing
ourselves at the moment for a big
increase of data factor 5 at least
coming in because we know there's a lot
of more satellite data coming in and
also our way getting more data in we are
better now to analyze data coming in and
more data in because we're now much
better in accepting data if there's
uncertainty with them because our
algorithm take part of it so that is
definitely increasing but the big
increase comes in factored 1000 in the
crease of models the center it's it's
not long ago that the grids were 100
kilometers and we're now talking about
less than 5 kilometers grid on global
scale and that's that is showing than in
the in the data amounts we will have but
I mean this is now all this is purely
what I said about the weather forecast
we're doing the media in the medium
range these kind of data but ECMWF and
this is its number for weather
forecasting there's a lot of other
activities which follow up from weather
forecasts where the focus is often the
beginning of a chain to use other
products and here we have a big
cooperation with the European Commission
you might have heard about the European
Copernicus program is a massive big
program by the European Commission to
make science and observations data much
more easily available for a private
citizen but also industry and we are
part of that one it's six services that
I've mentioned above atmosphere
Marineland climate change security
emergency on behalf of the Commission we
are operating the atmosphere and the
climate change and we're very heavily
involved in emergency because a flood
forecasting and fire forecasting we do a
lot the forest fire forecasting we do a
lot in a similar way so we are heavily
involved with this one so we'd play a
big part of this one it's one about your
Commission and just to mention the
atmospheric service monitoring service
is very interesting if you want to build
I want to look at data like air
pollution chemicals in the in the
atmosphere sand and dust which in some
areas have a big impact on for some
flight routing and things of that so and
there's an example here the column of
sulphur dioxide and the atmosphere so
it's very interesting to to check on
quality
pollution and quality all the data from
the camps is free and accessible for for
anybody to build products on and the
Commission is very keen of users using
this so there's a lot of activity so
have if you're interested in that go to
the data to the link I put there to the
data of the service and then the other
service I mentioned it's a climate
change service and this is mainly
reanalysis data the seasonal forecast I
mentioned and also climate scenarios
which not so many atom at ECMWF but we
say we connect them to the service and
the CTS the climate data store is is the
way how its presented is the portal on
its own and it's very interesting why
mentioning it is because a lot of these
datasets are too large the reanalysis
data set which is very very popular for
a lot of industries because it contains
for the last the weather of the last
decades so it's a record of the last
decades of weather very interesting for
industry a lot of products are built on
top of it but the data set is I think is
now going beyond 5 petabytes so it's not
something you just download and work on
so what exit the data it offers data
download but what it also offers is
actually an interface which allows you
to access the data through pison at on
the server side and it's all started
last year so if you want to have a go
did we're really looking for a feedback
but this is really a new step for us to
let users on our side do products and
what you do is this perhaps a better
shot you're writing your pison script so
you can you have seen with the
decorators I hope you see better than I
can from here and you define the
decorators your interface which
parameters you want the users to choose
and then you generate a graph or you can
generate a product but a graph
equivalency easier so here I plot for
the last 7 no 8 years the to meter
temperature so the ground temperature at
London so you can see the seasonal
variation and also the variation over
the day making the line very thick so
you can do apps you can develop little
applications on this portal and
the next step will be to have a little
App Store where you then can share these
kind of apps and make them available but
at the moment you can see you have the
code and you have your own area where
you can do your own little scripts and
stuff so if you're interested in any of
these datasets this is something you can
play with without having much to invest
on your on your site so now I'm starting
a little bit more talking about the
Python what I what we use it for ECMWF
we build a lot of systems we have a
service for forecasters which around the
world can look at our forecast so they
don't need to get all the data that can
look often that they cannot even get all
the data because it's not physically not
possible so this web browser is called
ec charts allows them to see this data
and there's a web interface where they
can interactively go select different
parameters look at ya hurricane
developments I don't go into detail this
one here because we presented actually a
colleague of us three years ago he
presented at you know but another thing
we do is we talked about downloading
data which you can go by going to the
web page select the data set and then
click it out but you can also do it
through batch which you might want to do
because otherwise you get a strain on
your fingers clicking all the data you
want and we allow it through pipes in
the Python interface we have and there's
information for the ischium debrief data
how to get and the copernicus data and
you can install these api's through pipe
i only put the links here because
there's information on how you can set
it up because you needed to access choke
and you have to accept that you that
you're the licensed condition which is
free but you have still to accept that
before you can have access another thing
we use a pison is we have massive big
sweets sweets are defining the workflow
we have at ECMWF data coming in assume
data is processed feed it into the model
have the model the different parts of
the model running then do the
post-processing archiving the data all
this has to be expressed and it has to
be done of course in a way that it has
dependencies assume this
finishes start the other job make sure
that money operators we are 24/7 so we
have always stopped working around the
clock they can immediately see if
something gets delayed is something so
we have a workflow manager called easy
flow and there this is the user
interface you can see on the right side
how the operator and analyst a
forecaster researcher can see how the
jobs are doing but to define these
Suites we use pison have defined a
Python interface for users to define how
the jobs are what has to run and how it
gets scheduled between the different
machines
because some workflow start on the
supercomputer and then go and processing
machines so it also goes beyond a across
machines so in that shows a bit we build
system we get organize our work with
pison so what's about the number
crunching and for a long time we have a
lot of number to crunch where time
critical so we we have to do it also in
the HPC but for a long time we did not
look at pricing we traditionally use a
lot of Fortran we still in the model are
mostly Fortran and we have now for
post-processing and most services moved
C C++ but we're now have now started
looking more and more in pison and it
definitely would say that the interest
the the environment and the price and
definitely has improved of what we have
seen in recent years are very happy with
that and I think you will find there's a
lot of num focus logos which we're
making use of so we use it a lot now for
the post-processing validation
verification of of the forecast but the
the real challenge is for us what they
have not talked about and I don't want
to talk about it we have quite a lot of
different formats which are not publicly
used formats are very specific to
metrology very optimized for what we're
doing and to get them all in these
standard tools that is not very easy and
that is often the challenge to make use
of we see there's a good tool but how do
we get our data and that's a very big
challenge and also for users we don't we
don't want users having to understand
how our data is organized because that
is not the main problem they want to
extract data they want to subset data
and get the data that want so we're
trying to abstract
in datacube so that users have a way to
access the data without learning
something very specific to metrology and
what we found very interesting what we
started using since 2 years now is X
array which is you can say more
multi-dimensional pandas and it has
really proven to be very good for us
especially for the user site how to ease
more easily access our data but this is
structures very much oriented to netcdf
a format used in metrology but not much
in operation metrology so what we did I
think there was a big step for us we
went to the community we invited we had
two PI's and workshops whoever invited a
key people from these packages to ECMWF
discuss with them how we can improve
this situation because there's really a
lot of good developments out there which
we want to make use of it's only that we
need to make it all so easy to get our
data in and we learnt a lot about we
especially we call now a new PI so
interfaces more the second-generation
pison interface it's the first
generation we started off with 15 years
ago there were just the same Fortran and
C interfaces we just transferred them
into Python so yeah your Python program
looked like a Fortran program just
Python syntax so you don't really gain
much out of it you just can say you do
it in Python in the worst case you've
got it often slower than also because
you did not make use of anything from
someplace and so there was an important
lesson also to to go out to the
community and really learn what we're
doing and one thing we're really
interesting is is developing like dusk
the the distributed processing of data
and we were lucky that we had actually
very good session at our last workshop
at ECMWF last year that we could have a
good session about it but very good
talks and discussions because it was a
real workshop we also should get back to
the bit we not just sit and listen like
here we had also round table and had how
we can proceed and how we can do it for
our community and whereas of other
services - it was not just us so we are
really interested to look at that
there's something we're now exploring
how we can do much more
tributon processing with tasks on our
data and just nice short URL in the
bottom if you want to have a look we
recorded all the presentations so if you
want to ever see what we've done
please follow the link I hope there will
be a PDF way then can click on the links
on the view okay and I said now how we
get our data and so there is XR a very
nice package it's done by the community
and how we can make use of it so we're
very proud that we hope did the right
thing of talking to the community and we
actually managed we have a format called
grip which it's very specific to
metrology not much known outside
metrology and we work together with the
community and a company called P open in
Italy how we could implement it and now
X array with an extension can now read
the group data directly in and that
means as a user you you only would work
with X array and if you x-ray used
before you don't need to learn anything
new to work with our data because you
can use well what you have done before
and the only thing is if you you say
when you know when you know I'm going to
if you if you're not a grip file you say
engine CF grip and then it knows that it
has to go and get the CF grip and lots
and then reads it so it's hopefully for
the users the easiest way to work with
it and after that it's a data array okay
I got to sign that my time is running
out just to mention historically for 30
years we we have also provided a
graphics package to do weather maps
it's very data away from the
metallurgical point of view so the users
has a very high level package to do
visualisation maps it's also now
pythonic and has been can be used within
Jupiter notebooks and but what I would
like to say is all these different
packages we have the decoders the
visualization the interpolation I did
not mention but they're all coming
together in what we call met view met
views our workstation batch system we
have at ECMWF
it had his own macro language which was
already very
very close to pison it was only close it
had not the module import and everything
but the syntax was very similar so what
we did now is we actually made it a
pison so you can actually also write the
batch script in jupiter notebooks and
it's very helpful for all our users who
use our workstation because what they
actually do is as analyst who do quickly
generate batch jobs they're actually
generating so they're setting up their
plot setting colors and then what they
do is they open let's say an empty pison
script and they're drag and drop this
icon in and it generates the code for
them so whatever they have to find where
the 2 meter information comes from
it's the they don't need to worry how
the code is so just drag and drop and
generating this code and then they can
just say visualize and then they can see
the data and that we have now
transferred all to pice and so that is a
can be used from python very quick word
we are that is new for us a year ago
that would have been empty slide and
we're now getting out github pipe i
condor we have a docker hub image we
really try to be there and as i said we
also try to have tools which users can
easily use so how you can say I
mentioned ready docker hop we have a
docker hub image if you want to play for
our software around have a look at that
its installed our software or the pison
interfaces and there is also a lots of
jupiter notebooks which you can see what
we are doing and how you could work with
our data yes
quickly I guess that is Stephanie the
ports like I also pitch a little bit
here now for us and we have job
offerings at the moment but also in
general I think quite interesting one
and as I said we're pushing quite the
limit of data and systems we very much
high performance computing web
developments we're really having very
interesting tasks so if you're
interested in that have a look at our
web page
what we also outsourcing and tendering
out a lot of our developing work so if
you have a little company or your
consultant you might want to have a look
at this page and we're looking generally
for help and can look for contractors or
for example in space
the air is like porting IDL code into
pison it seems to be something quite a
lot of people do because we realize this
we're not not the first one doing it and
and otherwise as I said we're now
getting to get up I mean we are also
wanting we had already always
contribution with other weather services
stuff regarding our software now we want
to put it out and really more visible
like the CF group I mentioned this is
all out was and please have a look if
you want to contribute to our I'm so
suffer because we're definitely open for
that and last but not least we're also
doing a sum of weather code we started
that last year so M we will
unfortunately slightly too early because
I have not published it on the 21st of
January we will publish our challenges
so we had a simple we have looked around
what kind of challenges talk to our
users what were little tasks which will
not manage to do and where we can need
help of the community and then we will
select you can apply for if you think
you can do something right a little
proposal and then we select five
proposal for over the summer with a
little bit of pocket money we work on
these problems and there will be some
pythonic one there will be one
definitely but one visualization one I
have to mention that so have a look at
that and see if that might be of
interest for you and that is how would
have to say for thanks
[Applause]